es gibt ein Command namens Schrägstrich
Klier selfie Sandra und dann ist ihr
ganzes Inventar leer ich frage erstmal
was sie im Inventar hat und dann mache
ich mir einen Screenshot davon damit ich
die Sachen wiedergeben kann Handy was
hast du alles gerade mit dem Inventar
kannst du mal kurz gucken ob du
eventuell eine Glocke aus Versehen
eingesteckt hast
okay ich bin jetzt wieder auf Youtube
der hat auf jeden Fall keine Glocke
dabei ist mir auch scheißegal weil ich
brauchte ein Foto von mir Inventar denn
jetzt wird folgendes passieren Sandras
Inventar wird jetzt geklärt
wir schauen mal wann sie es merkt
wo war denn noch mal die letzte wisst
ihr das noch gesehen ihre ganzen Sachen
nicht mehr gemerkt sie hat nicht mal
gemerkt
sie hat nichts mehr ich bin auf dem
Youtube für sie merkt es nicht
sie merkt es nicht für die 10 € dieser
und Darius wie merkt man sich
eine Ewigkeit später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Luca wo bist du komm sofort wieder bei
minecraft online minecraft online
ich habe keine Ahnung wenn du zum Arsch
der Welt rennst vielleicht es gibt doch
teilweise diese Zonen in Minecraft dass
wenn du zu weit von zu Hause weg bist
also ich gehe mal kurz schlafen sein ich
habe mir extra ein Foto von deinen
Sachen gemacht du kriegst natürlich
alles wieder denn wie bereits gesagt
meine pranks die nicht darauf Update zu
schaden sondern nur um etwas Witziges zu
machen
ja aber ich meine jetzt mit Haus zu
bauen oder irgendwie so oder was in die
Luft springen oder dann Papageien töten
habe gemacht
normal die Sachen geholt und
dementsprechend kriegt sich natürlich
auch zurück
ihren Mann
gibst du mir das jetzt einmal
[Musik]
was denn
ich will mal wissen wie man fliegt und
so ich habe das noch nie getestet okay
ich gebe dir das für genau 60 Sekunden
[Musik]
bitte mindestens
fliegen
[Musik]
du bist der mit Abstand dümmste Mensch
den ich je in meinem Leben getroffen
habe was los Bruder
mich
[Musik]
wenn du zu hoch fliegst fällst du runter
komm jetzt was denn
wirklich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so wenn hier jetzt ein Huhn rauskommt
dann wird das mein Haus wohnen ich gebe
das dir das Handy wenn hier ein Hund
rauskommen damit es dein Haus wohnen
okay mal schauen bei dir wohnen möchte
[Musik]
wer bist du denn hier Schlafenszeit
Leute
Leute ich bin kein Vorbild recht gut
wegen mir mein Abitur Abitur sehr dumm
[Musik]
Leute habe ich wieder
unfreiwillig irgendwie eine Chance in
Minecraft zum Leben erweckt die extrem
selten ist das ist so selten das ist
mega
was passiert denn jetzt her ich zeig's
dir ich habe ganz normal meinen Weg
weiter gebaut auf einmal rechts neben
dem Blitz eingeschlagen es kam ein
Creeper Explosionsgeräusche und dieses
Monster kam
okay was machen wir jetzt
[Musik]
also er greift uns nicht an ist
anscheinend nicht böse auf uns Sandra
[Musik]
oh oh oh jetzt habe ich auch noch so
stressigen der mich mit so einer Angel
verfolgt
dich Laser
[Musik]
hahaha
du weißt schon dass dein Schild
irgendwann kaputt geht ne dann lauf doch
einfach weg mach doch einfach dein Ding
auf doch einfach aus seiner Sichtweite
ich darf verkünden
der Bau für den Pferdestall geht los
mega cool ich habe Granit ist das gut
nein du hast gar nicht
Alter wie viel
ja einfach
96 Stück 96 ja es ist gut Digger damit
können wir uns ein granit-portal machen
weißt du was das macht was denn damit
können wir direkt ins Ende
[Musik]
du musst das Granit so platzieren das
ist also ein Kreis ergibt
doch seltener gebaut
[Musik]
Inspiration von sapixel von Youtube
umgebracht ich meine
ich kann jetzt mal zeigen was
was der Pferdestall jetzt hier so kann
wir haben hier Glocken so ein bisschen
so Pferde mäßig angehaucht die
pferdestelle natürlich ne mit ach ich
wollte dann einmal holen mit Wasser
mache ich gleich mit Wasser schön und
mit ein bisschen Heu und auch wenn du
mal rein gehst in so ein Stahl komm mal
rein
hast du wenn du mal nach hier oben
guckst da oben ist auch so ein Kiste
auch mit Heu und so
extra sonntags Dach gesetzt guck mal
wieder raus
junge fahr mich jetzt auch so Pferde
dann haben wir drei Pferde habe ich hier
so die Laternen dran hier sind die
Säulen und hier außenrum halt so ein
paar Sachen die so typisch sind so mit
Pferden bisschen Gras bisschen Heu
bisschen Pflanzen Sonnenblumen für ein
Bauernhof und halt überall keine
normalen Fenster sondern halt so klappen
weißt du
durchlüften kann hier
mäßig machen
heißt Laser das war wirklich aus
Versehen ich wollte echt nur eine Klappe
öffnen
sehr produktiv heute
ja fand ich auch gar nichts gemacht
unsere sagen war nicht auch gut ich
trenne die Verbindung Freunde wenn euch
der Stream gefallen hat dann folgt uns
gerne auf Twitch ja Lisa wir hören uns
die Tage ne ja selfie wir hören uns
[Musik]